we obsess over disney princess style
just as much as you do
but did you know that their looks don't
actually match up to their places in
history
here's how their clothes makeup and hair
should have looked like
if they were historically accurate
rapunzel's lace-up purple dress
is almost as much her signature look as
her long
long blonde hair but to be totally on
point with historical accuracy
we need to make some tweaks to her gown
according to the producers
tangled was set in the 1780s and at that
time
most wealthy women still favored a
two-piece style of dress
called a roblon glaze this consisted of
a split skirt robe that lay open over
the top of an underskirt
this petticoat was often heavily
decorated and embellished
snaps to disney for lacing up the front
of the bodice
that's spot-on but we need to make it
whiter
and we need to change the color scheme
that bold shade is
way too modern and by that we mean it's
so
vivid it would have been down to
chemical dyes which weren't in use back
then
rapunzel's gown should be a lighter
movie pink hue
of course we need to talk about the hair
naturally
rapunzel has to wear it long no matter
what time period she's from
and she wears it straight and slick down
her scalp
but to fit into this decade of the 18th
century it would have been
seriously curly and big all around her
head instead
in this on-trend style they called the
hedgehog
no really we're not kidding it's quite
the difference when we view the two
looks side by side right
it's said that frozen is set in the
1830s to 40s
so the fashion should take inspiration
from the late regency
and early victorian eras not to mention
scandinavian royalty back then
however elsa's famous blue ice dress is
much more modern
so let's rewind to get a more accurate
version let's start with her bodice
its definition is down at the waist but
actually at that time
fashion was all about the empire line
the fashionable silhouette
raised the waistline all the way up to
just under the bust
with the gown then flowing down loosely
from that point
sorry elsa no slinky skin skimming skirt
for you
and certainly no leg slit you can keep
the cape
but we just need to make some
adjustments rather than gauzy
it would have been made from thicker
embellished fabric
and forget about the off the shoulder
neckline you need puffed up sleeves
covering your shoulders please
as for hairstyles women of a certain age
wouldn't have worn their
locks in a hanging braid back then that
style was reserved for the privacy of
their bed chamber
in public elsa would have worn her hair
up in a fancy do
much like the style she rocked at her
coronation regency's style is much more
demure but
we can't help but love elsa's ice palace
cabaret style
of course we can't include elsa and not
include anna
but to keep things interesting we've
analyzed what her more casual outfit
would have looked like
disney didn't stray too far from the
traditional folk fashion of norway at
the time
but there are a few changes we need to
make to really nail the historical
accuracy
first of all ana's trademark cloak isn't
typical of that region or that time
women wore layers to stay warm so we
need to thicken it up
and make it into a practical shawl
instead her black bodice
is more swedish than norwegian she would
have worn
a white blouse with a colorful high
collared woolen jacket over the top she
would have worn a neck scarf too
that would have come in handy on her
trip to the north mountain after all
as for her skirt she wouldn't have had
all that fancy floral embroidery
it would have more likely been simply
striped with a bit of a decorative trim
at the hem
we need to switch on his boots which
women didn't wear
for patterned stockings and flats to
finish let's give anna instant hair
extensions
she can keep the braids that's the style
young unmarried women wore
but they never cut their hair these
side-by-side looks
aren't too dissimilar are they tiana's
huge
dress with its puffy skirt sure gives
the princess vibe
but it sure isn't in line with what
women wore in 1920s
new orleans the jazz age was all about
flapper style dresses
with dropped waists and straight skirts
and slinky materials
think carry mulligan in the great gatsby
the floor length hemline
needs to raise up several inches all the
way toward her knees
tiana's big hide bun is also typical of
disney princesses
dating all the way back to cinderella
but her do
is a don't for her actual time and place
in history
rather than long hair held in an updo
the women of that period wore their hair
short and slicked down in waves as for
hair accessories
tiana needs to swap that flower crown
for a feathered headpiece
moving on to her other accessories let's
switch the short string of jewels around
her neck
for a very long beaded necklace
stretching all the way to her waist
you know what disney did get right
though those elbow length gloves
we love tiana's great gatsby makeover
compared to her standard princess attire
what about you the costume designer for
moana
did a lot of research to create both
geographically
and historically accurate outfits for
the polynesian princess
the pacific trust even sent
representatives to disney with textile
samples
so the materials colors and style of
moana's crop top and skirt
aren't a million miles away from reality
but they had to take into consideration
the animation process
too like the slit in the skirt which was
included to allow for greater movement
on screen
if we look at clothing in tonga and
samoa 2000 years ago
it's plainer than what we see on moana
rather than intricately patterned tap a
material
moana would have more likely worn a
simpler swirl
and if you thought the crop top was a
bit revealing
actually tops weren't typically worn at
all but let's just keep that top right
where it is for now
as for the rest of moana's look she
probably would have had tattoos as well
particularly on her arms shoulders and
chest her
ink might have even extended to a
tattooed necklace so with her pendant
holding the heart of te fiti
moana would have rocked double bling her
hair should be thicker and shorter
worn in tighter curls and just shoulder
length
now we know there isn't too much
difference but what do you think of
these two looks
so now you've seen these five disney
princesses with their historically
accurate looks
do you prefer these outfits to their
original style be sure to tell us your
thoughts in the comment section below
and let us know which princess is your
favorite thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign